there's oliver on the left jeff bezos on
the right
we are about to go to space everybody
we are in auto sequences
[Music]
maybe
when that engine gimbal check occurs and
that engine swings they should actually
be able to feel it
in the cabin because it'll sway the
stack back and forth
there go the aft thin checks
there you see the engine gimbal check
just peeking out at the base of the
[Music]
rocket
all right here we go everybody thousands
of people contributed
years to this historic moment ladies and
gentlemen
it's time for blue origin's first human
flight godspeed first crew of new
shepard let's
light this candle
t-minus 16 guidance internal
t-minus 10 9 8
7 6 5 4
command engines start two one
go jeff go mark go wally go oliver
you are going to space
oh my goodness listen to the roar of the
be3 engine we are just about to pass
through max q
maximum dynamic pressure that was when
the stresses on the vehicle are at their
maximum
max cube max q is confirmed
beautiful burn on that be3 engine
liquid hydrogen and
liquid oxygen as the propellants it's a
nice
not just clean in terms of uh
beautifully performing but
what comes out of it it's steam right
to see to see the the
the glow of the of the engine underneath
the rocket just under our shoulders and
to know
that we've got a crew that is going to
space
it it just feels different doesn't it
gary
it is totally different
all right you can follow along of course
the speedometer in the bottom left
the altimeter in the middle of the
screen there
so far appears to be a nominal flight
all right coming up here on mikko main
engine cutoff that will be followed
shortly
by separation and at that point after
separation we're gonna
let the astronauts unbuckle and take in
the freedoms of zero g
there is miko main engine cut off
a beautiful shot down the new shepard
rocket
look at that view
unreal
awaiting separation here
and here we are you can start to see
stand by you're going to see the
separation of the capsule from the
booster itself
oh wow
wow
and there we go our astronauts have
passed the carmen line at about 328 000
feet
continuing their ascent you see the two
vehicles there
when the speed hits zero you know that
they've hit apogee their
maximum altitude and you hear they're
having
quite an experienced
yep just have to wait for it
who wants the skittles
one minute warning one minute warning
okay get in
oh there's that look at this it's dark
up here
blue control all of her palace is
perfect
[Music]
copy astronaut demo
astronaut visa
[Music]
copy
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for our first even flight on new
shepard so far a nominal flight our
booster is about to return
to its landing pad there we see engine
relight
the sonic boom
and booster touchdown welcome back new
shepard
a beautiful rocket that provided a
beautiful flight to space
what first step your booster has landed
blue controlled based on what's great
about the booster
and there it is our crew capsule with
our our four
crew members on board you have a very
happy crew up here i want you to come up
stand by drugs stand by drove
oh so far a nominal flight here comes
the crew capsule
back from space the drogues deployed
here are the mains out reefing and
coming to
full inflation
our rocket went over mach 3 and now
they're coming floating back down at
just about 15 or 16 miles an hour
about to join us home back here in west
texas after having gone
over the carbon line the internationally
recognized line of space
the world's newest astronauts
gary how you holding up friend i i'm
speechless
wow and those big beautiful windows
i've just got about a minute and a half
of
floating before uh the activation of the
skirt yet to
for a for a soft touchdown at this point
um there are sensors on board that are
detecting how high they are above the
ground
multiple sensors and just six feet above
the ground that that cushion of air will
will puff and they will have a soft
touch down almost like
just sitting in a chair
but i'm sure their adrenaline is bumping
first
and touchdown welcome back
new shepard's first human crew
to all of you all of you ah
what a day what a
people in this day and it works so great
for everybody who made this spot
thank you blue patrol oliver thank you
so much for everyone there was
amazing it was amazing
copy first step you have a very happy
capcom here as well
let's do a status check astronaut oliver
status correct copy
astronaut
i am unbelievably good
coffee
flute controlled bezos best day ever
yeah copy everyone
go ahead and remain in your seats crew
member 7 is on their way
shortly you will hear the capsule
off-gassing
my mission was accomplished i didn't
kick anyone
[Laughter]
that was only about five minutes
first up blue control your apogee with
351 210 feet
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
that was
i was surprised at how easy zero g was
yeah yeah it felt it felt very like
remarkably
natural
well what a day you can see our four
the the world's new newest minted
astronauts
are there on board discussing their
incredible flight of a lifetime
up to space and back wow
our team is now preparing uh landing
safety operations
the recovery crew has already uh
well minutes ago has left the barn there
to go
open the hatch you can see them there
they're arriving at the capsule
in the riviens you can actually also see
that the parachutes
fell very close to the capsule it means
that there's not much wind out there is
a beautiful beautiful day
not too shabby gary what do you think no
it was picture perfect
and and it sounds like it landed pretty
much exactly where we predicted that's
how they can get to it so quickly
they start moving even before it landed
based on
on the prediction of landing um we use
weather balloons that we launched
throughout the morning and that that
gives us a very good idea of where it
will land which are within a thousand
feet
uh what you're seeing that they're doing
um right now is is kevin sproke
crewmember7 is just making sure
everybody is okay and gives them a
thumbs up
they're also grounding the vehicle when
you go into space
you could accumulate pretty significant
electric charge
that's actually why we prefer that the
astronauts not get
out themselves so that we can ground the
vehicle of static charge which can be
quite strong
excellent and i think they're that kevin
sprogue our crewmember seven has given
the uh
given the thumbs up uh for all of our
our uh
our astronauts that are on board there
again jeff bezos mark bezos
wally funk and oliver damon what an
incredible day you heard them on the
audio
best day ever i mean this is this i feel
like this is our best day ever and we
didn't even get to go up to space
i mean what a day again congratulations
to the entire blue team our astronaut
crew and of course the friends and
family
of these uh incredible astronauts
they're just about the exit
the capsule here let's wait for that
moment there you see jeff in the window
felix is up here
yes
you're just moving one of the main
parachute lines to make sure it doesn't
snag the hatch when it opens
there's jeff thumbs up
cc safe jimmy
[Music]
oh
confirm okay don't you can go live
go to the camera
jimmy gary the architect of new shepard
congratulations to you man
congratulations give me a hug
this is just oh
what what a day
again thank you everybody for joining us
live for our first
human flight of new shepard our four
astronauts went to space
and back topping over 350 000 feet
well over 100 kilometers they've come
back
down safely we're just waiting here for
egress
our crew is going to get out of the
capsule and meet their families back
here on the ground of course their
families
that have provided so much support since
they were little kids
and dreamt of this to this day and this
moment
let me know what everybody's there
[Music]
get in here
all right katelyn you ready family are
we ready
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh
congratulations congratulations
oh my god
[Applause]
what a day again here a successful
launch and landing of the new shepard
rocket and crew capsule with our first
human flight crew there jeff bezos mark
bezos
oliver damon and wally funk
and their families there giving big hugs
all around what a moment so much emotion
from all of them the the elation did you
see wally
did you see wally when she came out you
know this
i told you she was just she was probably
going to do a summer you know
cartwheel as she came out of that
capsule what an incredible
incredible day let's just capture a
couple more moments of this again
space flight so much engineering so much
objective hard engineering technical
thought that goes into it but when you
put people on board
there's such an incredible emotional
component to this the
the the time the effort the blood sweat
and tears
you know this better than anybody else
again congratulations gary thank you
ariane
and congratulations to the entire blue
origin team
this might have looked easy today it was
anything but easy
to design a vehicle like this that is so
safe
that anybody can get on board from
wall-e foam
who today became the world's
oldest astronaut at 82 to oliver damon
who became the world's youngest
astronaut at 18. he joined us from the
netherlands again big shout out
to our viewers in the netherlands
congratulations you should be
very very very proud of your countrymen
i mean again in representing the next
generation
of people that are going to go into
space i mean i can't wait to see
what oliver does with his future i can
only imagine you heard him in the video
you know he he just wants to spread
spread the love spread the message that
i can't wait to hear their impressions
of
the you know the view from up there and
in fact i hear in just a moment we uh we
hope to be getting
a couple of impressions from our
astronauts we'll stand by
for that there you see uh
the friends the family you see our ceo
bob smith there
you see a couple of our other executives
of course this crew
safety team and it's champagne time
[Applause]
everybody
it's the only proper way to end the
space flight exactly the only proper way
to end
a space flight with a champagne shower
and man that is let me just tell you
that is the beginning
of the celebrations there is a lot more
to come
we are again not just the crew and the
families but
everybody at blue origin who has made
the historic day possible
[Applause]
oh there's a big hug from jeff to wally
funk
[Music]
thank you
for a woman who uh was
was denied her opportunity to go to
space in the 60s
she had to wait to the 2020s but man it
was worth the wait
there you see the bezos brothers hugging
it out
oliver damon you saw him earlier giving
his father a big hug
what a moment he saw the first hug when
jeff came out of the capsule
to his mother jackie followed by his
father
mike i mean
again what what a day what a day
to the thousands and thousands of
members of team blue you contributed
to today as well i know you are all
hugging it out
back in kent washington at our
headquarters near seattle
sending you guys a lot of love from down
here in west texas
what a moment
i mean granted you know gary we weren't
in the capsule
but my favorite part was hearing you
know the hooting and hollering
and the laughing you know jeff is known
for his big boisterous laugh
i mean he is uh he's having the moment
of a lifetime here and you can only
imagine
as they were floating around up there
you saw them say
gosh look at look at the views
[Applause]
gary is this as you i had expected it 17
years ago when you joined blue origin
you know we we like to blue blue we like
to you know
start at the end goal work backwards to
make the design
and then and then build and then build
forwards
when you sat there 17 years ago with
this
with the very small team at the time at
blue
is this what you would imagine it's
certainly what we hoped for but with
the size of the team when i joined blue
origin there were only 20 of us in a
warehouse
and it would have taken a huge leap of
faith to think that we could have gotten
to this point but we have
just just incredible uh you know
i've been here seven years we were at
300 so man you got me beat by
by a lot there but you know i can
remember when we
when when i joined the team and we were
talking about
this the moment the day that we were
gonna fly
people you know you talk about it but
it's here and it's now and i remember we
were talking about okay well what will
this video look like and what will that
video look like
it doesn't compare it doesn't matter
this is this is real this is so much
better than anything
that that we could have ever imagined
the the
again the emotional component to human
space flight we've had 15 consecutive
test flights which as you said earlier
is why we knew that it was we were ready
to put people on board this
this this rocket and that's what led us
to today
to know that we could do this we could
do this safely and to give people
the experience of a lifetime and i think
based on uh
based on what we see there i i think you
know job well done sir
job well done and not only did we do it
today we can do it again and again
and again and again precisely
absolutely love it that was amazing
everybody i want to thank you all for
joining us from around the world
for today's blue origin historic first
human flight
it's been a moment for the ages and
guess what
we're just getting started we've got two
more flights this year
and several more in the coming years i
want you to join us
a little bit later today we're going to
have a live press conference
on our website you're going to get to
hear the first hand impressions
from our four astronauts that went to
space and back
but to all of you out there if you like
what you saw
and you are serious and interested about
reserving your seat on a future rocket
ride to space on back with new shepard
we've got some exciting news for you we
are open for ticket sales
send us an email astronauts at blue
origin.com
we can't wait to fly you to space and
back gary
it has been an honor to share the desk
with you today
uh the architect of new shepard thank
you so much for your insights thank you
so much for all of your hard work and
all the hard work of your team that has
made today possible thank you aryan it
was unforgettable
absolutely the the road to space is
being built everybody and we took
a huge step today but we also need your
help if you're interested in learning
more about blue origin or joining
our extraordinary team please visit our
website
and if you'd like to commemorate today's
historic launch we also have some
mission patches for you there
and that's also where you can get some
apparel some collectible gear it is
all there look at that sweet patch so
beautiful with the names of our
of our new astronauts what a day
everybody my name is ariane cornell
thank you so much for joining us it has
been a pleasure and an honor to be
your host and of course until our next
launch
gradum ferocitor
[Music]
you